Hi, I'm Luke Wroblewski.
I'm a product director at Google, and
the experience I have that's probably
most relevant here is I wrote a book
called Web Form Design, and in
there I looked at all the little details
and nuances that make forms work online.
I think what you just said about
thinking purposefully about
forms is the key.
All right, don't treat these things
as one offs that you have to do.
Don't just copy a pattern out there and
assume that it works.
Actually take the time to think
what are you asking people,
how are you asking them that?
And if you put in a little bit of
effort, you'll have a lot of impact and
that's kind of the whole
essence of form design.